let's get into that first story we got a
tweet here from npr
more than 1 000 scientists and health
professionals are calling on spotify to
crack down on coveted falsehoods being
spread on joe rogan's podcast the
pressure highlights a trend podcasts are
becoming influential sources of
misinformation i want to pull up the
article but i want to point out the
framing technique they they pulled off
here from npr
they didn't say being spread by joe
rogan they said on joe rogan's podcast
what they're saying is
anybody who wants to interview some
interview someone who would say
something out of line with the official
establishment narrative must be stopped
it's not about joe rogan as an
individual it's about the fact that joe
would talk to someone who is considered
persona non grata by the machine now
that is a whole new level of creepy if
they were just saying joe has bad ideas
well then you could be like well you
know he's not the expert he's the guy
who interviews a lot of the experts no
no they're talking about the people he
hosts in interviews they don't like the
fact that he gives people an opportunity
to speak up and i also want to point out
the list was originally 270 people and
it turned out only 87 were actually met
you know practiced medicine i guess
technically you could say veterinarians
practice medicine and dentists do too
but some of them were like podcast hosts
now the list has expanded they ha
where'd it say they say an open letter
urging spotify to crack down on covet
blah blah blah the medical and science
and scientific experts slammed rogan's
track record of airing false claims they
go on to say the list has now expanded
to 1 000 people and you know what
so what
they're going after podcasts they're mad
that this is one of the last bastions of
of unfettered speech though there have
been podcasts that have been banned
here they go they did it to youtube they
did that big adpocalypse campaign the
media smeared them relentlessly now
they're going to go after all the big
podcast platforms but this is crazy and
just absolutely absurd i remember seeing
the 270
doctors that they first put out and it
was everywhere in the corporate media
and i was like let me just take a look
at this list and i saw a dentist and i
saw a political professor i saw a
veterinarian i saw
students i saw political scientists and
i'm like wait wait
what
you know
these people should be number one
ashamed of themselves because they
should be challenging these ideas not
trying to silence them and i made a post
about this and it went all throughout
twitter specifically saying these are
not practicing medical doctors now
there's a thousand of them i haven't
checked the list but i still remember
being publicly attacked by a
gynecologist on twitter who is on that
list being like he's calling me out he's
trying to you know blur the lines here
he's trying to spread misinformation no
we're not you could counter the
information you don't have to silence it
and when you type in joe rogan into
google news right now you get nothing
but smear pieces attack pieces that
literally look like they almost come
from the chinese cultural revolution
with double speak orwellian language
yahoo news has an article the problem
with joe rogan and white boys the
independent these experts say joe rogan
is an extraordinary
danger to society here's why npr of
course has more blatant articles about
online misinformation again
counter the data dr robert malone has a
lot of credentials he listed his
credentials he is someone who was an
extremely important part to this entire
process that the world is going through
with this larger experiment
challenge his ideas don't take out his
tongue because when you do that you
prove him right uh look at this one from
nj.com the long list of things i will
not be asking joe rogan for advice about
and it's got fauci he says i've been an
infectious disease expert for 50 years
and then joe rogan saying i get kicked
in the head for fun
yeah okay not anymore he quit kickboxing
but it's just so stupid
anybody who's ever actually listened to
his show know that he's an inquisitive
guy who asks questions of experts that's
it if they really wanted to play games
they could show fouchy and then they
could show peter mccullough or dr robert
malone that would be really interesting
voucher would be like i'm a bureaucrat
over the past 40 years and maloney like
i invented mrna vaccines how about that
one
but they shut down malone yeah there's
another thing about this though which is
this is what happens to any new media do
you remember the blogosphere do you guys
remember the blogosphere
yeah so this was like it was a while it
was like the in the early 2000s all of
these blogs were popping up and people
were getting their news from blogs and
so you had mainstream media outlets
corporate media outlets slamming the
blogosphere like i believe the press
secretary at the white house actually
used that term um saying you know you
can't trust these sources these are
terrible sources that's exactly what
they're doing now to podcasters they
don't like anyone that gets more popular
than their own you know corporate media
outlets that's why you know that's why
it's so important wasn't pj media like
pajamas media wasn't that the slam
against the bloggers like they were just
in their pajamas at home and that's why
you can't trust them
pants
i'm not joking that's real
terrifying i no longer wear pajamas
personally i cover late night tv and
late night tv gets so many facts wrong
on such a consistent basis where are the
lineup of doctors saying that stephen
colbert is full of it where are they did
you see colbert call for abolishing the
senate
he was like what's the point he's like
the democrats represent more people and
it's like represent does not mean they
agree with them that's that's that's
it's just it's fascinating
they don't like their their machine
being challenged that's that's the
obvious point but they're losing
and that's why i love i love the joe
rogan joe rogan the subject matter
because joe's winning and doesn't care
he doesn't you know what's really funny
i feel like joe's you know sitting on
the throne of biggest podcast doing his
thing and then mainstream media and us
are like just down on the ground
bickering to each other and complaining
about it and joe just doesn't care
how long will spotify have his back
though i think that's the big question
uh what's two years i think that'll be
an average age of of of contracts you
know and then once it's up they're going
to be like
but uh i actually making a lot of money
from him though oh yeah absolutely the
company was valued over a billion
dollars the stock skyrocketed as soon as
he came on the platform yeah i was kind
of bummed because uh
you know i was like when i knew that the
shift was going to be happening i was
like man i should have bought all the
spotify stuff right
because it just skyrocketed once i
didn't even think about it to be honest
in reference to stephen colbert saying
that we should abolish the senate or
whatever he was saying it was weird
because he was like the senate is the
most anti-democratic thing but what he
doesn't seem to understand is we're not
a democracy we're democratic republic
and the senate is the essence of the
republic yes it's a stop gap for
democratic mob mentality
stephen colbert
palpatine
that's giving him too much credit though
but not as funny as the emperor right it
would have been funnier if when he
called for abolishing the senate he just
like his voice changed you'll be
dissolving the galactic center i mean
that the the federal republic he's the
jester klaus schwab is the real emperor
palpatine in my opinion with everything
he's been pushing forward with the world
economic forum and the great reset uh
but but again joe rogan is as popular as
he is because he comes off as very
genuine very honest he has conversations
that a lot of people are afraid to even
think about and he entertains ideas in a
way that's not forced upon you in a way
that is naturally uh you know understood
and and and and just talked about in a
rational way rather than of course pr
corporate talking points and that's why
he is where he is right now
i think joe represents like you're right
a regular person
she does not yeah
for the longest time there's been this
conversation around like citizen
journalists and it's really funny
because people don't know what it means
citizen journalism referenced somebody
would be walking their dog and then see
something happen and then film it and
that's what it means you're a citizen
who happens to commit an act of
journalism but people who specifically
try to engage in journalism are not
citizen journalists but the conversation
around that was basically why should we
trust these individuals and a lot of
people said well look the suit on tv
talking to you as the authority doesn't
work anymore people have trust in
themselves
and they want to they want to talk to
trusted people they don't trust foreign
you know like like outside of their life
i mean kind of establishment elites they
want a regular person they they can feel
like their neighbor who can talk to them
so fauci represents the establishment
elite of we are smarter than you and we
know it and joe represents hey man don't
don't listen to me i'm an idiot but i
just got some questions but there was
this great clip going around i think
james lindsay shared it from the world
economic forum
uh in november and it was this lady
talking about how
uh the elites all are banding together
internationally and are working together
to get their agenda across but that in
in each country individually
um the lower classes don't trust the
elites and she was talking about this as
though this is some big problem
the rest of us don't trust our elites
you know we don't trust these people who
are telling us what to do based on their
own international conglomeration of you
know ideology and
wealth
reporting real quick i hate the elites
not every single person you know it's
not absolute but just like
fouchy and biden and the uniparty and
mitch mcconnell's in there these
establishments these ultra wealthy i
just i want to i'm dying to say
something because they're literally
calling themselves
we our got closer we're a lot closer but
like everyone else doesn't like us gee
you wonder why as of course we literally
went through an entire situation why are
you playing that man
that dog torturer i don't want to be
seen with that man but
they are literally in a situation where
they have profited off tremendously off
of this entire pandemic they have
created a situation where the rich are
becoming richer than they ever have
before and they wonder why don't they
trust us and of course their circle got
tighter and what's really surprising
about the world economic forum they
literally put out all of their plans
right in front of you they write about
it they said most about it they said it
straight out they discussed the great
reset and exactly in detail exactly and
then as soon as we all started writing
about like oh y'all have you seen this
plan this is this crazy plan the fact
checker swooped in and it started saying
that this wasn't actually real and it's
like look at the damn documents they
were right there these are they said it
they said it out loud yeah the corporate
media is like conspiracy theorists
conspiracy theories these are people
making it up but i'm like and they
literally just reverted new world order
into the great reset that's exactly what
what it is and let's be honest with it
and they figured we'd all be such plebes
that we wouldn't actually notice we
can't actually read they rebranded the
new world order and they still put out
all of their documents like the medieval
catholics who don't understand latin no
we know what it says they literally try
to make you eat bugs there's like short
little videos that they put out on
twitter saying eating bugs is going to
be great and save the world so check
this out check this out on january 20th
i was on twitter and the what's
happening page popped up with the great
reset is the world economic forum's
proposal for post covet economic
recovery reuters in the bbc report and i
just screen grabbed and put lol i
thought it was funny they keep trying to
do this thing where they're like the the
great reason it's just this it's just
that the funny thing is it reminds me of
when hillary clinton was campaigning and
she put on a southern drawl when she
yeah and like
she didn't realize the internet existed
and that human beings talk to each other
pretty old so what's fascinating about
the great reset the world economic forum
the davos group is i feel like it's a
bunch of 80 year olds who are like
how are people finding out about our
plan the great reset it's like
have those social media watches just
tell everyone what to believe and then
regular people look at it and go
yeah that's that's bs like we're not
cows or you know what i mean we don't we
don't just get told something and go oh
but it really it really is it when
hillary clinton put she put on that
southern dialect
because she thought she was going to
trick people into thinking that she was
from the south or whatever i get it she
is but she doesn't talk that way she was
a new york senator and then the video
goes viral and everyone made fun of her
and laughed and then she was like how
did i lose
it's humorous and elitist thinking that
they're above everyone else and
therefore they could get away with it
this is why the pope trudeau macron
biden kamala all the world leaders have
been saying the same thing we need a
great reset we need to build back better
they slowly and calmly tell you that
this is their plan openly and you're
deemed a conspiracy thirst for even
bringing it up and talking about it when
their plans are laid out and they're
implementing it right in front of our
eyes there's no hiding it yeah it's
right here yeah what they mean is we
need to solidify our power because
that's what they mean i want to give
some credit there's so little
self-awareness in our culture these days
calling themselves the elite i'm very
impressed by that that is cool
was that you i wasn't there but they
were like
based tim calling him elitist and not
elite i don't but i wasn't there
but it was the video was actually really
funny when this woman
where was she at the world economic
forum and she's like the elites she's
like referring to herself in that way
and it's just like there's one way not
to endure yourself with regular people
then she opened up her blouse there was
an e on there
it's like it's like a globo gym from uh
yeah
we're better than you and we know it
that's like on a i saw a tweet from
clint russell liberty lockdown liberty
lock pot if you'd stop referring
yourself as our elites i'd hate you at
least ten percent
you know it's funny though i feel like
it's the children of the previous
generation's elites and they say that
you know wealth only lasts a few
generations so you end up with these
like the the robber barons and stuff and
then over time they have kids who have
kids and now we have this global elite
that are kind of like the inbred royalty
who don't really know how to run a
system yeah so they've inherited all of
this they never earned it they never
fought for it and it's like they're
going through their own fourth turning
where the ship the great grandchildren
of these pre these past billionaires and
millionaires and and powerful uh you
know royals and politicos have no idea
what they're doing but they just know
they're better than you that's how i
told you that's i think we have to yeah
we have to really realize that nobody
really knows what they're doing i went i
mean i went to prep school with a lot of
really smart people who have no idea
what they're doing and they're you know
running the country now that's terrible
what's the point of being here anyway
being a human i i still don't know
that's that was a huge leap yeah it's
like there's problems with our country
why am i alive i know survival is like
part of it but other than that what's
the point i mean this is this is this is
why you know a lot of people say that
religion is very necessary to a culture
to a society because there are a lot of
people right now that have no purpose
and they're asking the same question you
are but they're they're being given
answers by the elites who want to
control and shape everything and so
they're telling them things they're
telling them crazy things and then these
people go out and write and burn things
down they're protected so they found
their meaning they found their purpose
but you know the crazy thing about it
they have their purported purpose you
know with these black lives matter
groups or antifa we got to fight for
against depression and it's like have
you ever actually sat down and asked
yourself what's what's next what's after
that what do you do
it's like these individuals are just
lost a lost generation and that's where
the cast is coming from but it's being
weaponized by the elites who want to
dramatically reshape the planet i'm
concerned about the kids wearing masks
talking about a lost generation because
if i've been raised not seeing facial
expression now than uh a hard thing to
navigate i know and you're bad enough i
know i'm all right semi weird but ian in
the elites want to party in a way where
their servants are clearly marked and
masked and represented by of course the
face diapers that they wear while of
course the ruling elites get to have
their galas and their lovely red carpets
where they get to be free and not have
to wear face diapers well christian and
i were just talking about this because
both of us have you know send our kids
to school and the kids are fully masked
and outdoors too i have to actually tell
my kid i do this waving of the face as
soon as i see him take the mask off take
this
adam adam carla has a theory about this
he says it's crate training you're crate
training the young kids to kind of obey
yeah and uh
i'm not gonna disagree with that because
give me something else because it's not
something you know when i get to the
when we get to school in the morning you
know i say to my son like yeah you know
you got to put your thing and he's like
okay time for my complicity covering
you know we joke about it because i want
him to know that it's stupid the whole
time i want him to fully be aware of how
stupid it is every second that he's
wearing it and yeah as soon as he's done
with school i'm like get that stupid
thing off your face a couple days ago i
posted a meme of you know students that
were told to be six feet apart there was
a police officer looking over them they
were outside with a mask and then the
tagline was like this is how you make
someone a slave this is how you raise
someone not to think independently how
to literally act like they're in prisons
and that's what they're doing in schools
i would absolutely recommend for you
guys to try to do anything you can i
mean uh both of you guys are in new york
city you guys are good i'm in denver
there's probably other families that
feel like you that would want to create
a homeschooling pod network that would
actually help your kids so much more
because i feel so bad for these these
kids they have to go but you know you
know what really bothers me is how
you know we used to see people from uh
southeast asia they wear max masks when
they're sick and i'm like i like that
idea like if you're sick and you know it
and you're and you have to go out and do
stuff like you wear a mask now with the
problem i i see is people aren't sick
but they're they're all just blindly
doing this thing
and then what that creates is it
polarizes we have hyperpolarization now
where there are people who are overtly
anti-mask and i'm just like yo man like
if you get sick you put a mask on if
you're not sick and you know you don't i
guess because
but
we're struggling to have the nuanced
conversations about what makes sense
and anybody who questions the mandate
for instance on vaccines is anti-vaxxer
right when like clearly everybody is
pro-vaccine you know except for like
there's many people who aren't but there
are people who have specific questions
about something specific the the nuance
is stripped out of it and i think it's
on purpose oh yeah they wanna they wanna
make you an extremist you say hey this
policy for kids is dumb well then you're
a you're a dumb redneck auntie but
here's the thing about making you an
extremist right i mean you have the
biden administration going after
uh domestic terrorists right they made
this they're like a big
department of justice thing and when you
look at what they're going after they're
saying that if you are
anti-government or anti-authority then
you are you know some sort of extremist
these are the terms that are being used
anti-government anti-authority
extremists you know i saw a bunch of
things that were like uh white
supremacist
anti-government extremist and it's like
what is this what is this about okay so
white supremacy that's bad sure
obviously anti-government
and so if you're opposed to the existing
power structure that makes you george
washington some sort of extremist
remember remember resist which erupted
in 2017
it was pretty cool and pretty mainstream
yeah for the whole yeah you resist
everything the man said for four years
whether you look and you weren't
supposed to look into the policies you
weren't supposed to understand what was
being proposed
he was in the uh government i think yes
right and you were just supposed to be
you guys entirely opposed you see that
story about the guy who needed a kidney
and because he didn't get vast that they
told him like guess you'll die that was
the craziest thing you know i was just
like this the lady on the phone
pure evil like evil incarnate you
thought it was gonna be like a giant
demonic man with horns in a business
suit being like i am the antichrist no
it's the lady at the hospital who's like
i know you need a heart but for for
reasons we don't care why you know you
decided not to get the vaccine so you'll
die now it's like
you're crazy or that lady in texas who
uh the guy was recording saying you
don't qualify to take this vaccine uh
sorry sorry not the vaccine you don't
qualify for this uh antibody treatment
uh because of you know the race in the
city
and then the media claimed it wasn't
true they're like no one's being denied
like half a dozen states yeah and it was
part of the uh part of the fda directive
i believe
one thing i loved was maude marin in new
york she was running for city council
but she recently posted on twitter she
was having some design work done in her
house and an architect showed up to her
house and asked her to wear a mask
and
mod said no and you're fired
we're done here
you know i wouldn't want that person
working on my house either people have
lost it man thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you